the Joe Rogan experience yeah I would
watch something like that except it's
just too much the first thought is just
too much
Tony dance to watch yeah I mean I put it
on my list but you know I'm gonna get to
that and does everything have to be like
a season you know does everything have
to be so drugged back to our subject
everything is either very condensed or
way too drawn out and you have to follow
it and it's not like an episode of
friends well you don't have to know what
the [ __ ] happened the week before and
you just tuned in the Seinfeld is not
dependent upon the week before right
it's all everything's a narc
and people binge I don't binge
I never binge ten ething i I have the
opposite problem I have watching a DD I
when I I love to watch TV it's the last
thing I do before I sleep at night
but unless something is absolutely
compelling
I don't watch more than 15 minutes of it
I'll watch 15 minutes of this and then
15 minutes or that and 50 meant
something else thing and then go to
sleep you know people are structuring
their Netflix specials that way because
of that people are doing their closing
bit first I read that somewhere that
yeah you have to we have to grab them
and it's why every [ __ ] drama is
something and then six months earlier
yeah you know we have to go back because
you have to grab them first and then and
it's such a tired trope yeah you know
it's like now that we've seen it a
hundred times think of something else or
just go really crazy and do something
linear well it's you know this whole
thing that you were saying before we do
have a second seven second attention
span or we have three hours I would love
to see someone try to make a movie like
Steve McQueen's LeMans because if you
don't remember that movie old Steve yeah
the old Steve McQueen there's no kids
there was a Steve McQueen before the
very talented director oh you know there
was a director Steven yes you do who is
he
was he just he he direct what you know
right he directed he's an African
American he directed 12 years of slave
okay
you
are you using your magic like body to go
war and what else to do he's a big
director he said he's a major major guy
that Steve McNair yes I didn't know who
he is
shame widows yes he just did widows
widows 12 yeah okay anyway I remember
the old state yes Alan who died of
cancer 1980 I believe I remember I'm
chasing cures in Mexico for wedding yeah
yeah lung cancer I think probably I
think he probably was a heavy smoker and
oh but yeah he was he was what about him
the movie LeMans is a real slow
beginning there's no talking for like
the first I don't know how many minutes
it's just you know people going about
their life on the racetrack like all
preparing for things no there's no chat
Oh
you ever try to watch a Hitchcock movie
oh yeah same thing
yeah I mean it just shows how different
the audiences are and how we have
developed or undeveloped I don't know if
it's that or if it's that there's an
expectation that people have a short
attention span and so that everything is
made for that expectation no they do
they do yeah I think they I do think
they really do I mean the more you I do
I I must say as someone who grew up when
Alfred Hitchcock was still was he still
making yeah he made a movie in 1972 I
was 16 I saw it in the theater it was
one of his last he was on his last legs
but psycho it was 1960 I was too young
to for that but he was still very in
vogue and a big director and I tried to
watch I did watch the one he made in
1956 the year I was born called
the man who knew too much I think the
story he made three times he liked that
story about the innocent guy who's being
chased by somebody and he doesn't know
why they're chasing him and the police
are after him but he's got to find the
bad guys before the police find him
it's Jimmy Stewart and Doris Day
it is I mean they talked about the
master of suspense I mean Jesus Christ
is like the master of keeping me from
falling asleep it's really subtle slow
I'm sorry but I think they've improved
on that I do maybe that sacrilege to the
movie community and Martin Scorsese
he'll write me a letter or something but
Jesus Christ I'd much rather watch salt
mmm you know there's a thriller that
robes or the Jason Bourne those movies I
feel like they took what Hitchcock was
doing and yes they revved it up and I'm
glad they did
Hitchcock's hard to get through we also
have to realize when Hitchcock was
making films they've been only making
films for 50 years there's a real even
left yeah then he started in the late
30s right you know I mean talkies had
only been around for like ten years way
back yeah yeah so I mean there's
something about that like even when you
think about stand-up like if you ever
tried listening to Lenny Bruce I
certainly have good example yeah I can't
do it doesn't work anymore contextually
we're in a different world
[Applause]